lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la relación que existe entre el
concepto de linealidad local en un punto
y el concepto de diferencia habilidad en
un punto así que la linealidad local es
la idea de que si hacemos un
acercamiento suficiente en un punto dado
aunque sea una función no lineal pero
ojo que sea diferenciable en ese punto
ha dado este acercamiento haga parecer
que se vea lineal así que déjame
enseñarte algunos ejemplos primero
pensemos en la función y es igual a x
cuadrada aquí la tenemos y claramente no
es una función lineal pero podemos hacer
un acercamiento a un punto y si nos
acercamos lo suficiente vamos a poder
observar que parece más o menos lineal
así que vamos a hacerlo imagina que
queremos hacer el acercamiento en el
punto 1,1 vamos a hacerlo
vamos a acercarnos al punto 11 tanto que
parezca más o menos lineal en ese punto
y observa aquí esta es que esta
propiedad de linealidad local es muy
útil cuando estamos intenta
aproximar una función alrededor de ese
punto así que por ejemplo podemos tomar
la derivada en el punto 11 usar esa
derivada como la pendiente de mi recta
tangente encontrar la ecuación de mi
recta tangente y usar esa ecuación para
aproximar los valores de mi función
alrededor de x igual a 1 y tal vez
pienses que no es muy útil para una
función como x cuadrada pero puede ser
muy muy útil para una función mucho más
compleja pero bueno lo más importante
aquí en el punto 11 es que observes esta
idea de linealidad local y que también
es diferenciable en ese punto ahora
veamos otro ejemplo de una función que
no sea diferenciable en un punto y que
tampoco veamos una linealidad local así
que por ejemplo tomemos el valor
absoluto de x pero déjenme desplazarlo
un poco para que nos encima con la otra
gráfica así que pensemos en el valor
absoluto de x menos 1 de hecho ésta es
una función diferenciable en todo
los puntos excepto en esta esquina que
se forma aquí en todos excepto en el
punto 10 para cualquier otro valor es
diferenciable pero en x igual a 1 no es
diferenciable y ya hemos hablado de esto
en otros vídeos y podemos usar esta idea
de linealidad local como una prueba de
diferencia habilidad y una vez más esto
no son matemáticas muy rigurosas pero
nos da una buena intuición observa no
importa qué tanto nos acerquemos
seguimos viendo esta esquina filosa es
imposible construir una única recta
tangente que pase por este punto por el
punto 10 de hecho podemos construir una
infinidad de estas rectas tangentes pero
ninguna va a pasar por el resto de la
curva así que ojo si tienes una esquina
filosa como el punto 10 en este valor
absoluto es un buen indicador de que no
seremos diferenciables ahí bueno ahora
vamos a alejarnos de nuevo vamos a
regresar nos a nuestra escala original y
vamos a trabajar con otra función donde
la ausencia de diferencia habilidad
por una esquina sino que el acercarnos
se empieza a ver lineal pero empieza a
parecerse a una recta vertical así que
un buen ejemplo de esto es tomarnos la
raíz cuadrada de digamos 4 - x cuadrada
esta función es la mitad superior de un
círculo con radio 2 y enfoquémonos en el
punto 20 porque justo allí no existe la
derivada observa que si nos acercamos lo
suficiente podrás ver que justo en el
punto 20 empieza a parecerse a una recta
vertical y es por ello que no somos
diferenciables en el punto 20 bien
regresemos ahora otra cosa que quiero
mostrarte es que bueno en todos estos
casos hemos hecho un acercamiento muy
grande para apreciar bueno que tenemos
una esquina en esta función del valor
absoluto o que en el punto 20 o en el
punto menos 20 hago extraño pasaba justo
allí no era diferenciable pero hay
funciones que normalmente no se ven en
las clases de álgebra de cálculo
pero en un principio se ven como una
esquina bien marcada y cuando nos
acercamos de manera adecuada cuando nos
acercamos demasiado podemos ver la
linealidad local y de hecho son
diferenciables en esos puntos así que
borremos todo esto y vamos a buscar un
buen ejemplo para ello se me ocurre la
función y igual a bueno si ponemos x
elevado a la 10 observa esta gráfica
empieza a tener unas esquinas por allí y
si ahora hacemos esto elevado a la
potencia 100 ahora parece que tenemos
unas esquinas mucho más marcadas y para
exagerar más voy a poner la potencia a
1000 así que observa en esta escala
parece que tenemos una esquina en el
punto 10 pero de hecho esta curva ni
siquiera pasa por el punto 10 si x es
igual a 1 que es igual a 1 pero ojo
aunque parece que en esta escala tenemos
una esquina bien marcada si empezamos a
hacer un acercamiento esta esquina se va
a suavizar y esto es bueno porque la
función de hecho es diferenciable para
todas x
tal vez esta sea una función un poco más
exótica de lo que normalmente se ve pero
si nos acercamos vas a ver que todo
cambia así que vamos a acercarnos por
acá me sigue pareciendo una esquina bien
marcada pero si nos acercamos lo
suficiente ahora puedes ver que esto
empieza a suavizarse y empieza a curvar
observa si nos acercamos lo suficiente
esto empieza a verse como una recta y
estoy seguro que esto es bastante
difícil de creer cuando tenemos la
escala original pero ahora el punto
donde parecía una esquina la distancia
al acercarnos podemos encontrar la
linealidad local y como no tenemos una
recta vertical y esto ocurre para todo
punto en esta curva por lo tanto podemos
decir que somos diferenciables así que
el punto aquí era que hay veces que nos
tenemos que acercar demasiado con la
herramienta de demos que es la
herramienta que estoy utilizando y que
es muy útil para este tipo de ejemplos y
aunque estas no son las matemáticas muy
rigurosas nos da la intuición de que si
nos acercamos lo suficiente
vamos a ver como una curva se parece
cada vez más a una recta entonces ese es
un buen indicador de que esa curva es
diferenciable y si te mantienes
acercándote y se sigue pareciendo a una
esquina o si te acercas y se ve como una
tangente vertical bueno entonces estoy
seguro que algunas preguntas deben de
surgir en tu cabeza bueno eso es todo
por este vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente